>> Greg: TIME FOR...
WELCOME TO -- IT'S JUST TOO
EASY.
A STORY TOO EASY TO RIDICULE,
MAKING IT TOO HARD TO IGNORE.
PETE DAVIDSON, THE NICE KID FROM
"SATURDAY NIGHT LIVE," HE GOT A
TATTOO OF HILLARY ON HIS ARM.
ONE'S FRIENDS ASKED WHY IS THAT
IS BECAUSE HILLARY WAS A BADASS.
NOW HE HAS SOMETHING IN COMMON
WITH HILLARY.
THEY BOTH HAVE A ASS ON THEIR
ARM.
HERS IS NAMED BILL.
I COULD SAY THIS IS THE FUNNIEST
THING PETER HAS EVER DONE BUT
THAT'S TOO EASY.
I COULD SAY IT'S THE FUNNIEST
THING TO COME OUT OF "SNL" BUT
THAT'S TOO EASY.
HILLARY.
HILLARY WHEN THERE IS SO MANY
OTHER MORE PREFERABLE OPTIONS.
LIKE ALL GORGEOUS DOLPHIN.
LOOK AT THAT OR MAY BE A
DELIGHTFUL UNICORN.
SO SPECIAL.
MORE WHY NOT ME?
LOOK AT THAT.
IT'S BEAUTIFUL.
EVERYONE SHOULD HAVE ME ON THEIR
BODY.
TATTOOWISE.
WE GET IT.
YOU CARE.
YOU ARE MORALLY SUPERIOR BUT
WOEFULLY TRANSPARENT.
TATTOOS ILLUSTRATE DECISIONS
BASED ON FEELINGS AND WITH
SOMETHING YOU REALLY REGRET.
LIKE CHOOSING HILLARY AS YOUR
CANDIDATE.
I WANTED TO DO THIS STORY SO WE
COULD TALK ABOUT TATTOOS.
I WILL START WITH YOU, DANA.
IF YOU GET A TATTOO, WHAT WOULD
IT BE?
>> Dana: WELL, I THINK, YOU
KNOW, I AM NOT FOR TATTOOS.
THIS IS PRETEND.
I WOULD GO WITH MY MAIN MAN,
JASPER.
>> Greg: THERE YOU GO.
A VERY HAIRY ARM.
>> Dana: ANOTHER REASON I AM
TERRIFIED OF THE TATTOO.
DOESN'T IT HURT TERRIBLY?
>> Greg: IT DOES.
THAT'S WHY YOU GET DRUNK.
TONS OF SHOTS, A COUPLE PAIN
YOUR TATTOO, IF YOU COULD.
>> Kimberly: I HAVE NO TATTOOS
ON MY BODY.
LIKE DANA, I DON'T DO THEM.
NOT GOING TO HAPPEN.
HOWEVER, TO PLAY ALONG, OR
ROLE-PLAY, AS THEY SAY.
I WOULD GET RONAN, MY MUNCHKIN.
WHAT A CUTIE.
>> Greg: ALL RIGHT, JESSE.
>> Kimberly: THAT WOULD BE ON
MY SHOULDER.
>> Greg: JESSE, I AM DYING TO
KNOW.
>> Jesse: I PUT A LOT OF
THOUGHT IN THIS AND I CAME UP
WITH DR. SEBASTIAN GORKA.
I THINK HE WOULD LOOK GREAT ON
ANY APPENDAGE.
THERE IS SOMETHING TERRIFYING
ABOUT HIM BUT REALLY WHOLESOME
ALSO.
HE IS THE MOST FASCINATING MAN,
THAT COMMERCIAL.
FASCINATING ON MANY LEVELS.
I THINK IT WOULD BE A NICE
CONVERSATION PIECE.
WOMEN WOULD LIKE IT.
MEN WOULD LIKE IT.
CRIME?
>> Kimberly: EVEN BETTER.
>> Jesse: IF HE IS GOING --
>> Juan: IF HE IS GOING TO GET
HILLARY, I'VE GOT TO GET A
TRIPLE.
EVERYBODY.
HANNITY, LAURA INGRAHAM,
JEANINE PIRRO.
I REALLY WANT THE GIRLS ON
EITHER SIDE OF HANNITY BECAUSE I
WANTED A PROPAGANDA SPECIAL.
>> Jesse: THAT IS FAIR AND
BALANCED.
>> Kimberly: I THINK IT'S
ATTRACTIVE.
>> Greg: I GOT A TATTOO.
THIS IS ON ME.
I GOT ATTACHED TO OF TATTOO FROM
"FANTASY ISLAND" HANGING OUT
WITH THE RUSSIAN POP STAR DUO
TATTOO.
THEY ALL HAVE THEIR HANDS UP.
ISN'T IT PLEASANT?
IT IS INTERESTING.
>> Greg: SHAWN O'ROURKE.
I GAVE HIM AN UNUSUAL MISSION.
ROGER STONE HAS A TATTOO.